I want to jump to this story from the
Daily Mail Biden Administration sued for
censoring Free Speech lawsuit accuses
president Karim Jean-Pierre Mary Poppins
of disinformation and slew of officials
of a disturbing amount of collusion with
social media firms to quash critical
stories Republican Attorneys General of
Louisiana and Missouri are behind the
lawsuit it named 67 government officials
or entities as having worked hand in
hand with social media companies to
censor stories and elections coveted in
the economy they're seeking to depose
key defendants and will ask a judge on
Friday this egregious attack on our
first amendment will be met with an
equally full-hearted defense of the
rights of the American people Louisiana
A.G Landry said just a moment ago in the
previous segment Kathy you were
mentioning that uh
well I guess the gist of the idea is
people need to know what's really going
on they need to be able to challenge the
politicians they need to be able to
understand what's happening in their
communities but now you have more and
more evidence piling up the government
is actually working with Big Deck to
make sure people can't know what's
actually happening in their communities
yeah so when we talk about why it is
that a poor person would keep voting
Democrat it's because they are being
locked in they're they're locked in a
bubble where they can't get accurate
information it's becoming increasingly
harder now I do think with all that
being said we are still winning this
this cultural battle we're seeing you
know The Daily Show Trevor Noah's
quitting CNN's in a death spiral Brian
stelter's canceled all of these awful
narrative mongers smear Merchants are
being ousted losing their positions of
of of power and influence and regular
people are finding their voices through
the internet we what we see here is the
government desperate to make sure you
don't know what's actually going on
around and that's a problem that's a
problem right can you imagine if Trump
had had weaponized the FBI the media
Facebook and Google and how mines will
be blown right now you know people hair
would be on fire to be running through
glass pane windows right the world will
be coming to an end but it is I mean
it's so Un-American and I believe and I
believe it is um just so very dangerous
I mean think about the first five rights
of the um um of the First Amendment uh
freedom of speech freedom of religion uh
uh freedom to um Allure I'm forgetting
because I'm on television right now but
freedom of speech freedom of religion
freedom of the press freedom to
um mobilize what's that no not mobilize
fully assembled that's one form of
mobilization radius of grievances yes
exactly right and now but when you go
you know it's all five of them but when
you go down all five of them you will
see how this particular Administration
has just trounced uh have pounced on
people's
um just basic fundamental rights right
freedom of speech I mean go out there on
Twitter and put in Monkey pox and see
what happens to you right like they're
shedding all of that kind of
conversation down talk about you know uh
covid and the vaccines or any of those
particular things and there are certain
sites that will shut your conversation
down altogether like uh what you call it
YouTube like YouTube exactly yeah right
I mean I go figure and so and then and
then you wonder why people are I mean
when you know when we when we were on
the campaign Trail for 13 months we were
traveling over 1500 miles every single
week and we were going all across
Pennsylvania and I mean I saw you know
and and the people are just amazing we
have some of the most amazing people
within the Republican party but I can
assure you people are stressed people
are like in little pressure cookers
right now right and then when you when
they want to express themselves and
speak out and talk about the various
issues that are concerning them and now
they're told what you can we're going to
suppress we're going to Shadow band
we're going to you know boot you off all
together together that is not creating a
healthy environment for our country and
that's just on social media now you
begin to talk about you know inflation
and gas prices and what's going on you
know on the precipice of World War III
all of these particular pressures it's a
lot yeah I think the demoralization it
leads towards mental poverty like you
were saying you never felt like a victim
growing up and because of that you were
basically wealthy I mean you may not
have money you don't need necessarily
money to be have a wealthy State of Mind
friends and family and love and desire
to create I was loved I was loved I was
cared for and because of that you
created something great yeah and people
that have no faith or that are think
that they're victims and are living that
lifestyle May tend towards destroying
themselves or allowing themselves to be
destroyed I mean but think about it if
you're living in a culture where every
every time you turn around as a young
black man let's just say as a young
black straight man let's just say
everywhere you turn you're being told
you're a victim you're being told you're
inferior you're are being told that you
know that because you have white skin
you have privileges that my brown skin
does not provide me that somehow my
brown skin is barring me from a world
that your white skin gives you access to
can you imagine if that is your daily
diet morning noon and night how you will
show up in the world right and so and
that is the narrative you know regarding
the censorship stuff I feel like not
that states have revolted for less but
that like if you pressure people living
that they can't have normal
conversations in their daily life
they're going to tell you to screw
yourself and they're going to form their
own government and if 39 states in the
United States told the federal
government no more no no no you're not
going to censor us we live free in our
states the problem is if state
governments start censoring their own
people that's why we built a federal
government was to protect people from
States overreaching on their citizens so
that's the first time we've been in this
well that's basically Shea's Rebellion
is an example of the Massachusetts
Government just
imprisoning people at will bringing in
the federal the federal government can't
actually pardon people for State crimes
no but it can it can send in federal
troops to make sure that a state doesn't
like the free things violating the
Constitution exactly it was violating
the Federal Constitution yeah and um
this is kind of the first time in our
history that we've had a situation where
people feel like the federal government
is infringing on their rights more than
their states and it's I don't know
terribly Like You Luke you were saying
you feel like it's like this new this
order this change of order I'm not sure
how you phrased it earlier
um maybe it's just inevitably the the
liberal economic order the american-led
rules-based international economy is
fading away and and we're just seeing
like the struggling death throws of a
but the thing is it's that's not it
because it's us it's the people of the
United States no no no we're leading
this thing the unit party for the
longest time was an elite class uh look
at the media for the longest time if you
wanted to be a journalist you had to
come from a rich family because the
companies were based in New York City
the big ones and if you wanted to work
there you had to be an intern meaning
you weren't getting paid or you're
getting paid very little and how can you
afford to live in New York City getting
paid very little your parents paid your
bills this was a well-known problem in
the media industry even up to 10 years
ago and it probably is still a problem
in New York though it's probably been
alleviated to a certain degree now we're
seeing that regular little old people
can take a GoPro put it on their monitor
screen and talk for a few minutes and
eventually grow that into a podcast
where they have a voice
that's changing the game and this means
the establishment unit party is losing
that class-based control they've had for
the longest time and they had tried to
consolidate their power at the
corporation legalities or you can like
say hey you can't sue me you can't take
anything from me you got to take it from
that fake Corporation I built and then
they can move their corporation offshore
have bank accounts offshore and they're
basically the oligarchs running the UNA
party is this this wealthy corporatist
it's it's you know it's pretty simple
here tyrants can't rule if they can't
control information because people will
speak out against their tyranny and this
is exactly what they're doing and what
they've been doing I've been screaming
about this for many years now people
called me a conspiracy theorist people
called me a cook people said I was
insane I was crazy there's no way that
the federal government is involved when
it comes to censorship of big Tech
social media they're private companies
they get to decide and do whatever they
want themselves because they're private
entities let the free market speak and I
was screaming on the top of my lungs it
is not a free market it never was a free
market intelligence agencies helped
start up a lot of these major
corporations and on other hand who's
playing with their phone right it's
getting hot is that you or me I think
it's Kathy put the phone down ma'am pay
attention uh and and and and truly truly
what is happening here is them saying
you know what we're gonna go after
comedians scientists Doctors medical
professionals politicians we don't care
we're just gonna censor and shut
everyone up for our own personal benefit
because we want to control every aspect
of this existence including the thoughts
in your head and that right there is
just too much power for any individual
to have they should be sued out of town
they should lose their positions of
power because they were very
irresponsible with it and they're
endangering all of us by trying to
literally enact thought control so my my
concern is that even if they're sued and
they're told legally you can't do it
anymore and they're like okay we'll stop
the private companies are private
companies they've got like the the prism
spy Network we know that they have like
secret spying networks that they'll just
do it anyway I mean that's my concern
learn is like de facto rule what how do
we really you need encryption you need
decentralized communication sources
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there